can you hear me kuba their villages  burned to the ground your enemies aren't  far behind we need to go now you have  questions I can tell you get three why  only three okay that was your first  question I don't understand what's  happening this is the beginning of your  story  your family is very powerful your mother  used my magic to save you and bring me  to life what are we going to do we're  going to find your father's armor it's  the only thing that can protect you many  years ago I was cursed this great  adventure is my destiny your magic is  growing stronger you need to learn  control  showoff  fathers fortress this late  claim your birthright c'mon give this  story a happy ending  if you must blink do it now the opposite  of the Titanic yes just so you can hear  the four most precious words in human  language GUI gah